vous voilà bien morose monsieur stop que
c'était vous savez que le conseil de
l'ue aux enfants s'est réuni afin de
créer une nouvelle ferme oui je le sais
puisque françois et moi nous avons tiré
à pile ou face pour savoir celui qui
représenterait le jardin et ses
fonctions qui a été désigné elle aurait
mieux valu que ce soit vous ma chère
amie avant de bon sens aurait soufflé
dans cette île n'est ce pas mais dites
moi plutôt de quoi il s'agit et je
pourrais vous donner mon avis et bien
pour me reposer de mon travail de
sculpteur de peintres de ma fonction de
président de la fed de l'île aux enfants
et de mes nombreuses obligations
mondaines je voulais offrir à l'île aux
enfants mes services mon talent afin de
m'occuper de la nouvelle ferme
non ils ont trouvé mes exigences
inacceptables france doit te n'est
que de mendier vous au des choses bien
simple pourtant je voulais que les
cochons prennent un bain ou une douche
une fois par jour que le coq ne chante
pas avant que mes volets de ma maison
soit ouvert pour ne pas me réveiller
ah non je voulais aussi que les vaches
ayouch en deux par deux mais tout est
resté dix tard je dois avouer que je
reste moi aussi voté contre vous parce
que les animaux seraient peur avec de
telles conditions
j'en ai fait des concessions chers amis
je ne sais pas moi je réduis les les
touches des cochons par exemple ce n'est
pas une raison vous avouerez pour nous
mais mon ennemi mortel
responsable de la ferme et rémy martin
oui je veux parler de ce ballot de
lourdes où ces incapables
voyez j'ai même pas bien le nommer vous
allez trouver son nom mais attention je
sais que vous le considérer ainsi mais
ce n'est pas pour ça que je suis
d'accord avec vous
u19 vous êtes toujours en colère j'ai de
quoi vous avouerai n'est pas du tout
monsieur disney je vous assure que non
c'était un très mauvais service à vous
rendre vous vous êtes beaucoup trop snob
pour vous occuper d'une ferme
pourquoi monsieur justement les imaginer
oui tu ne conteste rien ne vous rendent
visite au moment où vous aller traire
une vache
à lait on pouvait faire attendre une
vache et encore moins une colle à terre
avec vous avez réseau très cher amiable
avait rendu un très bon service je vous
remercie beaucoup excusez moi mais cette
matinée m'a beaucoup fatigué de faire
une petite sieste au moins avaient très
chers amis à bientôt
vous savez pas monsieur
bravo casimir honte a confié une charge
très lourde mais très belle robe oui oui
d'ailleurs je suis venu te voir pour ça
j'ai quelques problèmes
j'aurais aussi besoin de poids françois
il faudra convoquer les enfants mais ce
sera fait casimir il va également
falloir ton tableau noir mais ça tombe
bien justement il est tout installé là
bas un parfait mon frère tient pendant
ce temps là mais cette cassette sur ton
cas ces temps forts d'accord je vous
rejoins voilà qu'est ce que tu peux
écrire françois mais certaines occasions
offre alors un jeu je te dicte ma
distincts les historiques rien écrit
bien bergerie bergerie et à blain et
tables porcherie forciori poulailler
vous l'aviez pas de zèle ni charyn niche
un clap yan lapierre et à colombier et
un colombier et voilà c'est tout les
essais tout c'est tout maintenant tu
peux appeler les enfants les enfants
venez vite installé vous serez dont
casimir a besoin de
ce qui se passe les enfants dans la
nouvelle ferme de l'île aux enfants il
ya tous ces nouveaux bâtiments trois
gardes et
une bergerie une
étable d'une porcherie un poulailler il
niche un clapier et un colombier quasi
moyens que via savoir je voudrais savoir
dans quel bâtiment de ma ferme je dois
mettre ces animaux c'est facile selon
des noms casimir et je ne les connais
pas tous par coeur mais je les ai
enregistrés sur la cassette que j'ai
donné à julie
formidable julie envoie le premier cri
s'il te plaît
c'est qu'une vache winch effectivement
c'est le meuglement d'une vache j'espère
que chez eux nos amis avaient trouvé
donc la vache habite
dans une étable très bonnes réponses
julie le cri suivant
c'est ça c'est un cochon c'est un et
c'est le grondement du cochon où habite
le cochon
le cochon à la grave dans la porcherie
je m'en souviendrai ensuite julie s'il
te plaît
un loup non non
j'ai entendu elle et ce cri des enfants
oui ou collomb je crois que c'est ça
qu'il est le cri la colombe du pigeon
c'est un roulement il roucoule très bien
où habitera le pigeon
donc dans le colombier vous aviez
d'ailleurs chez vous continuez à bien
chercher ensuite je lis
c'était un mouton et le mouton habite
dans la bergerie il y en encore julie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
% des poules qui caquettent
et les poules habits trop ça sedan le
fou d'alice ils le crient suivant s'il
te plaît
le chien habitera dans la niche voilà
j'en ai encore julie s'il te plaît non
ici ici il coûte voilà celui là casimir
jeu j'y suis désolé mais j'entends rien
non je n'attends rien c'est un petit
animal tu sais qu'il ya deux grandes
oreilles et qui adore les 40 ans
c'était le cri de la pince à à oui il
fait si peu de bruit de l'attaquant n'a
rien entendu oui tu es content casimir
excusez moi oui nous a dit que le lapin
dans les clapiers
ça va non ça ne va pas du tout je ne
suis pas content du tout parce que
chaque camp les animaux de la ferme à
prague à une maison et il n'y a rien
pour moi pas la moindre application pour
moi alors ça ne va pas du tout je suis
furieux et je donne ma démission là